4俺の名前はエドワードエルリック
みんな俺のことを得だと呼ぶよそしてこいつが折れないもう
[音楽]
僕はただ付を避けるべく
僕のことをみんなただと呼ぶよあっはぁ
誰かを治すならというわけで今日は俺たち錬金術地である実験をしたいと思ってるんだ
あるあとだただ見せてやるな
[音楽]
ています
等価交換しませんかというわけでやれようぜえか見なきゃ人が結構いそうなまさにし
てるんですけども
ものの穴って知ってるかものには価値が同じ価値のものを交換すること
等価交換という
そうだ音だ1
はっはっは物の価値は人によって違う俺たちにとっちゃこの小さな賢者の石全然価値の
ないただの石ころだが非常によってはこれがすごい数なるものに感じてしまうことが
あるそうならを当然
aether はっはー
だから今日は等価交換といっても実際やってることは物々交換等が等価交換ということ
によってちょっと4
かっこよさが出てあげたくなっちゃうかもしれないそうだろう当然
というわけで物々交換じゃなくて今日は等価交換
やっていこうと思います同じ感じじゃないと交換するダメなんだね交換してくれる方が
この石と同等な価値であるものを交換してもらいますその子がしてもらったものを
ペッパーを焦がしてもらったものをさらに別の人と同等のたちのもっと硬化してもらう
あなた公がしばらくたものを別の誰
彼の同等の価値だと思うどこ交換してもらうと長靴がお菓子続けるとどこまで俺出すに
とってかつ出るものじゃないのか
見ていこうをどうぞ
20はっはっはん
[音楽]
またばとん
こっち向いて
こっちからこっちこっあっはぁ
しての
dare
[音楽]
誰も来てくんだよなぁ
この弦者の位置と交換しないかベンチャーです
賢者の支援をありがとうございました
その脚本なんだからわー
お待ちましょうな人と逆ぱお花
鼻笛
[音楽]
ブーブーいいね
いい賢者の石から iphone の充電器に変わりました
これ結構 jr が入ったからやってるんです
昨日
それなんかジュエリ契約したが1られてやってきたこれと toto の価値のものと
ならば高額するんだ
この箱とかすごい
福田ってどうもありません
に任せるよ男鹿署でと思う
ありがとうん
そういう iphone のケーブルから gu のどこどこの服に変わりました
ボカシじゃああー
だけど iphone ケースに変わってしまいましたいいだろ iphone ケース
がモバイルバッテリーに変わりました
うえっこれまずでに行くかでまだ使わないんで
小田氏はヤップで本当に良いのバスでこれ
なんか純正の lightning ケーブルのイヤホンもらいました
でもこれた分野だこれで終わりて言ってにありがとうございます
可愛くデー
交換しまった lightning ケーブルのやロースト星梨花ず無償の命を焦がし
てしまいました
二葉3勝山市のはお弁当東京 v があってくれて一人で可塑性のおしりかじり牛の麺
となんかラッキーボックスと弓矢を上げます左可愛いな
子会社化いやー
火薬て交換してしまいましたイヤリングになってしまった
つばのクローバーすまぬがといっ
by 今ですよ
アリアナ
目指せ技で交換してしまいました四つ葉のクローバーですなんでいただっけ
んジェネレーションの方やつでずーっと伺いします
物と物を
交換しないと
この友の家先生
ハッカーはっきりパーティーフィードマジでダークニャンとこ貼ってくれたありがとう
ございます
フェイアゴが割れ始めたね俺の名前はエドワード l 位
みんなで枝って呼んでくれパネラーとコーナーしてくれましたこれでもスクイーズだ
から多分なんか気持ちいいやつやつですね
今でしたらスクイズのブーバはいいなぁアップなんか
マナー squeeze からえーっ可愛いキューピットブーバーあり現実の良さか
ロボット見ているのだ
怖い
動くんだぜこのロボットっ
動いてくださいホラー
プロフ水
いろいろやっ
しかしん
思ってほしい赤いございました
と思ってないです
家の中のことだそうです少ねぇ
それと
これ
どっちが欲しい
小柄僕部に泥上げやー
朝たらー
元気だこうしてただファーストの等価交換は整列し
俺の弟は
帰ってくることはなかったんでしょうねえ
そしてをとっ
検定なぁ
[音楽]